écologistes partisans de la
désobéissance civile ses militants
bloquent la place du châtelet à paris
ainsi que la rue de rivoli depuis le
début de la semaine peut-être pour se
dire que tel girard a eu du mal à nous
rejoindre ils bloquent aussi ils
bloquent aussi londres faut-il les papas
de la totalité de londres mais mais mais
plusieurs artères à londres dans le
cadre d'une d'un mouvement et d'une
opération concertée dans tout le monde
occidental depuis le début de la semaine
faut-il les déloger au contraire les
encourager et bien en tout cas il y en a
une qui apprécient cette anne hidalgo la
maire de paris moi je soutiens toutes
les actions pacifiques je pense que
lorsque ces activistes lorsque des
jeunes aussi manifeste tous les
vendredis en disant on fait la grève de
l'école parce que la question du climat
est là et si on la règle pas si nos
générations nous aujourd'hui nous les
adultes qui sommes en responsabilité
nous ne posons pas d axer leur avenir
que nous sommes en train d'empêcher on
est en train de les empêcher de rêver
leur avenir et de construire leur avenir
je vivais trop peut-être sensible à ces
arguments je craque c'est important de
relever son avenir c'est important dans
la vie sauve à venir c'est même
important de pouvoir activement aidé son
avenir par exemple en allant travailler
par exemple en commerçant quand on est
commerçant va en se livrant à tout un
tas d'activités humaines que ces gens là
vous prêtant veulent vous empêcher
d'exercer au nom de l'intérêt supérieur
de la cause qu'ils défendent mais
entendu ce qu'ils disent elles on a
essayé de manifester de façon classique
et ça ne sert à rien donc on est obligé
de poche il y ajoute les gens qui
partagent leurs idées politiques
anticapitalistes qui se présente aux
élections et qui sont battus dans ce cas
là on évoquera si quand on est battu on
ne peut pas imposer son programme mais
cela dit c'est facile à dire
rappelez vous quand la police a délogé à
coups de gaz lacrymogènes
au pont sully des manifestants écolo qui
avait fait à ce sit-in ça a déclenché
évidemment ateliers et en plus une
enquête de la police de la police de
l'igpn donc vis-à-vis d'une opinion qui
trouve qu'ils ont bien raison de faire
ce genre de mouvements pour secouer la
léthargie
et et à battre le grand capital c'est
compliqué pour un gouvernement de faire
tout simple moi j'appelle ça faire
respecter les libertés
voilà le blocage de ce point était une
sorte de répétition puisque c'était déjà
ce bon fond extinction rébellion qui
était à l'origine
alors si vous ne savez pas quoi faire ce
week-end et que vous êtes à londres ou à
paris et que vous avez envie de vous
amuser bien vous pouvez les rejoindre en
tout cas si vous avez envie de vous
amuser comme ça
[Musique]
m
guillaume bernard je vous sens chaud
bouillant pour la naturellement écoutez
si c'est ça l'avenir de l'humanité qui
nous propose effectivement je ne
souhaite pas faire partie de cette de
cet avenir là c'est ludique bon écoutez
c'est la rave party public est imposée à
tous ça me paraît pas tout à fait à un
exemple à donner aux autres jeunes
j'ai bien passé pour à rebuy à la terre
rien qu'on va coûter très bien pourquoi
pas d'en faire la première fois ça
serait la première fois naturellement il
ya deux choses qui me semblent
importantes la première c'est que on
constate quand même que parmi certains
politiques pas tous sains et certains
politiques dont madame hidalgo lorsqu'il
s'agit de gilet jaune qui bloquent les
rond points
c'est scandaleux mais lorsqu'il s'agit
donc de deux jeunes à moitié drogué
c'est ça ne pose pas de problème elle
bosse ça ne pose pas de problème
bah écoute et j'espère qu'ils le sont
parce que tu comprends mais comme ça il
vaut mieux qu'il le soit donc non les
gilet jaune il faut les débloquer ce
sont des pouilleux c'est les classes
laborieuses mais quand ce sont des
jeunes comme ce qui se comporte comme ça
elle en revanche on peut admettre qu'il
est bien bloque tout le monde ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point c'est
que je crois qu'il ne faut pas s'y
méprendre sous prétexte d'un discours
sur la question écologique
c'est en fait un discours beaucoup plus
politique de la décroissance du
malthusianisme qui est tenu et ça en
revanche moi je veux bien débattre et
c'est importante de débattre de ses
idées là mais ils prennent la façade
bien pensant bien agréable d'avoir
généré une solidarité de demander une
solidarité entre les générations pour en
fait défendre des idées politiques
qu'ils dissimulent et qui sont des idées
extrêmement marqués et radicale alors je
dois dire que nos internautes sont
relativement d'accord avec eux en tout
cas si l'on en croit ce petit
ils sondage qui n'en est pas un puisque
ce n'est pas un échantillon
représentatif mais représentatif des
internautes qui suivent point de vue
c'est la question du jour pour être tout
à fait précis sur lefigaro.fr faut-il
déloger les activistes d'extinction
rebellion c'est oui à 90 %
donc ce sont les internautes du
figaro.fr qui ont été interrogés sur ce
point
étienne girard avez vous envie de les
défendre oh oui je vais alors je vais
pas les défendre complètement mais je
peux peut-être apporter une nuance quand
même arrivé en retard à cause de pas que
de la cause du à cause du métro mais qui
serait en partie tombé en panne
à cause de bon sens j'en sais rien en
réalité
bon ils créent des perturbations
extinction rébellion s'est même
revendiqué c'est la différence avec par
exemple nuit debout qui restait sur une
place et qui ne perturbait pas l'ordre
public corps et et place de la
république
voilà quand on est quand on crée des
perturbations
on craint trouble à l'ordre public et
donc il faut s'attendre à un moment à
être délogés ans mais en dehors de la
loi
donc il ya une légitimité à un moment à
les déloger
maintenant qu'on a dit ça on peut avoir
aussi du dit fermement dans
l'application de la loi
effectivement s'ils sont à côté d'un
pont il faut peut-être réfléchir à deux
trois fois avant de faire pour faire
respecter la loi risque et une
dissipation de manifestations dans le
dans le désordre et qui risqueraient
d'attenté à la sécurité de ces
manifestants il faut prendre en compte
le fait qu'il revendique une
désobéissance civile non violente on
peut pas assimiler ça à une
manifestation comme une autre il faut
prendre en compte la nature de ce qu'ils
défendent donc moi je serai sur une
position de relative indulgence ou en
tout cas d'arbitrage de la part des
pouvoirs publics selon les perturbations
c'est à dire les laisser manifester
pendant un moment et quand les
perturbations devraient deviennent trop
importantes
effectivement il faut disperser la
manifestation avec une stratégie comme
ça ce qui se passe et que vous laissez
la première fois cinq jours donc le
challenge c'est de tenir plus longtemps
donc vous en faites vous encourager ce
genre de vous juger par ailleurs des
difficultés nature à sion complète de ce
qu'est la désobéissance civile
attendez quand quelqu'un comme henry
david thoreau prônent la désobéissance
civile c'est pas en bloquant les
commerçants en envahissant leur
propriété privée
en empêchant les gens d'accéder à l'or
alors maison donc non il ya une grande
table ou agression ils ont fait de payer
ses impôts pour protester contre des
exactions gouvernementale bon ici on est
dans quel pays qui est pas aux états
unis donc on a ici effectivement une
véritable désobéissance civile mais qui
ne consiste pas à gêner effectivement la
liberté de circulation d'autrui et par
ailleurs il faut quand même revenir sur
les soubassements idéologiques de ces
mouvements là parce qu'on a beaucoup
parlé de religion est l'islam
cette semaine et à juste titre moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on évoque ce
mouvement là qui est une nouvelle
religion qui qui qui émerge sous nos
yeux qui est une espèce de néo paganisme
qui déifie nature sauvage qu'il faudrait
absolument affranchir de toute empreinte
de toute interférence humaine ce qui est
des conduits apprenez un anticapitalisme
radical au nom de la sécurité
environnementale comme s'il y avait d'un
côté les sociétés pré industriels qui
seraient des havres environnementaux et
de l'autre des sociétés riches qui
serait d en faire mais c'est une
dichotomie qui est complètement
fallacieuse aujourd'hui on sait que la
question climatique est aussi et in fine
est une question de développement
économique parce que plus les pays sont
riches plus elle gagne de la résilience
pour précisément résister aux
intempéries aux défis climatiques du
futur donc ces gens là sont en train de
prôner une religion anticapitaliste
complètement contraire aux solutions
qu'il faudrait apporter pour résoudre
les problématiques environnementales et
la revendique parce que quand ils ont
occupé le centre commercial italie 2 ils
ont tagué les murs du calvaire du
week-end dernier vous aviez moreau
capitale il y avait même un couteau en
céramique
en allusion en référence au meurtre
perpétré c'est le problème de ce type
d'organisation c'est que ça mais elle
tout un tas de groupuscules à
hétérogènes et dans lesquels il ya des
idées qui sont tout à fait composite est
pas toujours les mêmes c'est à dire que
on a des militants écologistes purs jus
si je puis dire et se mêlent dans ce
type de a-2 d'activisme débridé des
coloniaux ou des indigéniste de cette
façon là il est difficile de différents
mais qui et qui de fait groupuscule là
mais il ne pense pas tout ça dans la zad
en tout cas la zad de notre dame des
landes l'islamo gauchisme est
incontestablement représentés et c'est
vrai que l'on peut vraiment s'interroger
sur le fait que derrière la défense
intéressante est sans doute nécessaire
de l'environnement équilibre
environnemental se cache en fait une
idéologie alors qu'elle soit
anticapitaliste ça ne gène pas a priori
par principe mais qu'en revanche elle
soit repenti civilisationnel c'est à
dire qu'en fait l'homme serait un
parasite pour la nature essayez donc ça
évidemment c'est beaucoup plus
problématique c'est lié parce que jadis
on contestait le capitalisme sur sa
prétendue incapacité à évaluer la
condition des masses alors aujourd'hui
maintenant que la pauvreté recule que
l'humanité fait des progrès humanitaire
précisément assez spectaculaire et bien
ça devient une espèce d'idéologie de
substitution c'est à dire qu'on peut
plus contester le capitalisme sur le
terrain de la productivité alors on va
trouver d'autres arguments d'autres
prétextes le capitalisme détruit la
nature sauvage détruit des petits
oiseaux détruits ceci cela et donc il
faut l'année entre la morale aux oignons
et bien d'autres raisons et sans mettre
en cause leur vie on raisonne toujours
notamment dans le cadre de cette
fixation comme l'a été notre dame des
landes
c'est que personne dans les pouvoirs
publics ne pense à taper au portefeuille
on sait très bien que parmi les gens qui
sont des
des militants à l'année des permanentes
des occupations plus ou moins pacifique
aider des gens affiliés à ce genre de
mouvement il y en a une très forte
proportion qui vit grâce au rsa et grâce
aux allocations chômage une centaine et
à qui voudrait empêcher qu'on lui
nuisent pourrait s'intéresser aux gens
qui perçoivent ces allocations et à leur
comportement
qu'est ce qu'un état a aussi besoin et
hejira ou plutôt est ce qu'il est
souhaitable que il l'est peut-être
s'exprimer ce genre de mouvements bat
pour éviter des mouvements plus
importants comme une forme de soupape de
sécurité à ce que j'ai compris c'est
plutôt aujourd'hui la position de la
préfecture de police de paris un gars
qui ne bouge pas qui n'est pas à les
déloger
pour le moment les militants
d'extinction robillon c'est vrai qu'il
faut prendre en compte cette donnée là
que ce mouvement se revendique comme non
violent ce qui n'a pas toujours été
évident dans le cadre d'activisme
écologistes ah oui ça doit rentrer en
ligne de compte des réunions de la
préfecture de police
quand il faut arbitrer sur le maintien
de l'ordre
guillaume bernard le principe de la
désobéissance civile c'est quelque chose
qui vous qui vous choquent ou pas un
long pont du tout non non non je vais
partir du moment où une puissance
publique deviendrait tyrannique où elle
violerait le bien commun il n'y a pas de
raison de considérer que un pouvoir et
par principe légitime
le principe sur le principe sur le
principe au liberia ce que vous dites là
c'est à dire thomistes mais le fait que
l'on puisse effectivement considérer
qu'à un moment donné le pouvoir violent
et l'intérêt des parties et l'intérêt du
corps social il n'y a pas de raison que
l'on ne puisse pas cherché à comment
dire à contester ce pouvoir le tout le
problème évidemment c'est de savoir qu'
il faut en accepter le risque
or on peut pas effectivement comment
dire revendiquer le fait de deux de
commentaires de pratiquer la
désobéissance civile et en même temps
effectivement demandé la protection et
rouspéter lorsque l'on est par exemple
délogés par la police
pour le coup d'accord
d'ailleurs c'est amusant parce que dans
les rangs d'extinction rébellion on a
senti une certaine déception à ne pas
avoir été délogés plus comme ça on joue
le martyre vieux souhait est donc est
donc là dans les rangs dans les rangs de
ces activistes on se demande s'il faut
plier bagage alors qu'en pensent nos
internautes cab ronito nous dit je sens
que ce mouvement va vraiment changer les
choses on sent une certaine ironie genre
de commentaires de notre internaute et
nicole qui va la décadence de notre
civilisation
moi j'ai lu un commentaire intéressant
sur ce conflit cette semaine c'était
leur appel alors ça ne vous dira rien
vous êtes trop jeune mais au fait que le
dernier quand le service militaire
existait il y avait des jeunes qui
voulaient pas faire le service militaire
quitté des objecteurs de conscience
mais du coup il faisait un service civil
mais qui duraient deux fois plus
longtemps
en d'autres termes il accepter les
conséquences de leurs erreurs de leurs
engagements ou de l'heure il ne faisait
pas supporter aux gens par exemple dont
il nous entravent la circulation c'est
ça aussi la grosse différence
moi ce que je crains c'est qu'en fait
ces mouvements là ne soit comme sont que
le début en fait d'une radicalisation du
mouvement écologiste puisque dès lors
qu'on est convaincu que c'est la fin du
monde
dès lors qu'on est convaincu que c'est
l'apocalypse légitimement la fin
justifie les moyens
et aujourd'hui vous avez de plus en plus
de de plus en plus de figures
intellectuelles écologistes qui sont
décomplexés à l'idée de théoriser une
dictature à l'idée de 2
théorisé la nécessité d'actions
éventuellement terroristes pour nuire à
un système qu'ils estiment mortifère et
c'est là où en fait on entre dans une
espèce d engrenage infernal qu'on pourra
désamorcer que si on combat l'idéologie
apocalyptique qui sous tend ce genre de
mouvement eh bien écoutez souhaitons qu
on en arrive pas là surtout avant un
week-end sinon ça va françois fillon est
de retour vous souvenez que le candidat
ait l'air à la dernière élection
présidentielle s'était retiré de la vie
politique mais il est intervenu hier
c'était chez nos confrères de la radio
télévision suisse romande pour commenter
entre autres l'action du président
macron il est revenu sur l'attitude du
chef de l'état face au gilet jaune
notamment la décision de lâcher entre
guillemets plusieurs milliards d'euros
de dette sociale pour faire cesser le
mouvement et françois fillon l'a trouvé
emmanuel macron un peu petit bras